hello I'm ETA Segev the senior kernel
developer at Wolfram research and today
I'd like to talk to you about some new
ways to deploy Mathematica as well as
ways to control your computer and your
networks from it I will focus on the all
new Wolfram script both interactive uses
and running script files then I'd like
to talk about some language level
networking features as well as some
supporting functions the experts among
you may be familiar with full from
script or Mathematica script we've had
since version 8 which allows you to
write self-contained Wolfram language
strips in version 11 we've completely
rewritten from script greatly expanding
its scope it now includes running
one-shot evaluations from the command
line API functions in the cloud package
files automatically exporting to a
variety of formats as well as a new line
wise mode let's start a live demo and
see what happens
a simple example is wolfram script -
code dollar version which evaluates
dollar version and a local kernel in
this case it returns 1100 for Mac
however wolfram script doesn't need a
local kernel if we just add - cloud
it'll evaluate in the cloud if we
haven't previously connected it will ask
us to authenticate we see that the
result will be 1100 for Linux because
that's what our cloud servers run to
evaluate a cloud API just specify - API
with a URL arguments are supplied using
- arcs since we've already authenticated
it doesn't ask us to log in a second
time see from the output that we could
have supplied an optional argument why
we can simply add y equals world after
the X argument and supplied both
arguments to run a package file we just
say woven script - file filename good
afternoon I am a while from language
1100 script I was first executed in
Urbana Illinois on the 24th of August
2016
my next couple of examples I'm going to
need something on standard info for
which I'll use a file containing some
pound rome's
one of the advances in version 11 is
that there's now a language level way to
refer to standard input namely dollar
script input string here I'm going to
string reverse that input and I'm going
to use palindromes txt as my input we
see that the file is completely reversed
with the first line coming last however
suppose we wanted to just reverse each
line of input well then we can just add
dash line wise to our input and now
every line will be stream reversed
individually now let's talk about
Wolfram language strips as an earlier
versions you can create self-contained
full from language scripts for UNIX
environments new in version 11 we
support unix-like environments for
Windows such as cygwin and mingw also
all the new options including cloud
evaluation can now be used before I
start my demo let me just mentioned that
the contents of the script files can be
found in this notebook for later perusal
my first example takes the names of two
cities and returns the distance between
them in kilometers as we can see the
contents of this file are very simple it
simply declares that it is a function
taking two cities which uses
interpreters to interpret the
command-line arguments as cities and
then computes the geo distance between
them my second example illustrates that
there's a language level way to refer to
the script and its arguments if we call
square stardom with no arguments dollar
script command line contains only the
script name on the other hand if we call
it with several arguments they all
appear in dollar script command line and
that's the all new Wolfram script now
I'd like to describe some Wolfram
language functions which are helpful for
system administrators first of these is
host lookup it allows you to convert
host names to IP addresses and IP
addresses back into host names ping time
is obviously a version of the well-known
ping utility for
network timing there we carry the
histogram of pinging the Wolfram comm
website 100 times we also have a new
family of functions for cooking
management suppose we were to read from
Wolfram calm and wolframalpha.com we
might ask what were all the cookies
received while reading from molten comm
or what are all cookies received in the
current session or we could clear all
the cookies another new set of
functionality is related to encryption
you can create symmetric and asymmetric
key pairs and encrypt and decrypt
expressions here we generate an
asymmetric key pair and encrypt a very
important message 42 using our public
key that encrypted object can only be
decrypted using the private key which
must be kept secure another new function
is file system and it allows you to
easily apply a function to all files in
the directory or directory tree first we
look at the sizes of all the files in
dollar installation directory then we
might take a look at all the files in
the first two levels of dollar
installation directory this will return
a nested Association we still see the
two files we saw above but now for each
directory we get another Association for
system files it's empty because system
files doesn't contain any actual files
it contains only additional directories
on the other hand Mac OS has an
association of file name goes to value
pairs where we see the new wolfram
script for example the last new function
I'd like to cover today is byte array
this provides efficient storage of a
list of bytes we were to create a list
of a thousand bytes and convert them to
a byte array that byte array would only
occupy a little over one kilobyte in
memory this is different from just the
list of numbers which is eight times as
large because on the 64-bit machine
every integer is eight bytes long this
is obviously very useful when sending
and receiving network traffic it's also
used internally by other data structures
if we look inside the encrypted object
it's above we would find the bytearray
hiding inside of it those are the new
functions I wanted to cover today I've
listed here some additional resources
for learning more about these and
related functions I thank you very much
for your attention and now I'd like to
see if there are any questions